more international responsibilities the
challenges for German foreign policy in
the interview the head of the Bundestag
Foreign Affairs Committee Norbert Rudkin
the West is drawing closer together as
Russia distances itself from European
values
that's something the US president has
just said and it sounds as though the
world is becoming more polarized is a
polarized world easier to cope with
along that clutter come - no I don't
think we're heading back to that kind of
situation we had in the past it's not
polarized it's a completely new
situation how does one deal with such a
breach of the rules in a globalized
interdependent world a world that can be
split up into blocks one response which
I approve of is for Europe to be more
unified clear in its message and perhaps
also to take a more active role in
foreign policy
PolitiFact or dr. Tuttle huge state
garden there are some here in Germany
who say they understand Russia's
position former Chancellor Helmut
Schmidt for example he said he could see
things from Putin's point of view can
you understand that I know I can't
that's the clear answer but nonetheless
there is a tendency for some in Germany
to be a bit quick to accept Russian
propaganda and I can get a solution in
using words like fascist pushes a button
with us Germans because of our history
as I saw but as this well there are
different views and assessments but
there will be a variety of motives for
the people you're talking about some
will have a specific interest in the
region but that's probably a small part
with most it's probably fierce August
what will happen to us these are these
element
that's what does it mean in an economic
sense will a situation that's now
political and economic suddenly escalate
and become a military situation there's
a lot of fear there and a certain
defense mechanism comes into it as well
at the end of the day were obliged to
become more aware and to look after
ourselves
thus of us but we are affected most and
we do have a political role to play
come on but we're never alone within the
European Union or within our
transatlantic partnership but we do have
our own responsibilities we're not just
passengers along for the ride so non
Indies are freezer when it comes to this
crisis Germany is perhaps the country
with the greatest responsibility and
that's something we're not used to
that's fun once it was a pig does it via
fun for decades it was different we have
to get used to this new challenge
psychologically and politically and we
have to do it faster than we'd expected
of sushi Louis wouldn't pull it is
governing one Simon Ellen tempo adds
Godard from tenuto scenario is that
happening within the coalition
government and within Parliament is
there unity among the major parties or
are there different views don't oh she
deposits or
does give demon Olson does we're all
there are always new once's it would be
strange if that wasn't the case but the
government is unified I've thought for a
while that perhaps the different voices
of this grand coalition would come
together over foreign policy in a
positive way it evens in the bush
diamond built what do you think is a
snitch incidentally it's not just the
coalition it's a broad sweep across
Parliament including the Greens
that form this consensus Olson consents
in deutschland in Parliament in the
politic Apple
insufficient clintus allosaurus like the
situation now sounds like a russia
crisis but of course it's not
it's a Ukraine crisis the escalation of
events and Crimea has taken focus away
from the fact that the Maidan protests
were against a corrupt government is
Germany and Europe doing enough what a
Germany in Europe doing to support the
process is fin de viande element a minor
strategy I think there are three
elements to the strategy the first is
giving priority to diplomacy dealing
with Russia politically because Russia
helped to bring about the original
political crisis in Ukraine and it
became a Russian crisis because of
Russian aggression the second part of
the strategy is supporting Ukraine both
politically and economically that's a
big part of it and the signing of a part
of the association agreement which
former President Viktor Yanukovych
rejected has had an effect the IMF is
involved and were engaged in political
and economic reforms both of those are
interconnected and both are needed in
Ukraine by the north window cleaner that
sounds a bit like a meta-level when you
consider the line up in the interim
government the defense minister has
stepped down for being overcautious a
Deputy Prime Minister from the far-right
Svoboda party is responsible for
minorities one presidential candidate
thinks shooting Putin in the head is a
reasonable option is it going to be
possible to work politically with the
people in Kiev I'm Smitha manfully to
show how that encounter as it's legal
it's a transitional government that has
come about through a revolution and has
been voted for by the current Parliament
that Parliament is there because its
members were elected but it's a
transitional government and I'm of the
opinion that Ukrainian politics need
fresh legitimacy as soon as possible
there needs to be elections not just
presidential elections
mentoree elections to then above and
beyond that there's the question of
political culture the ability for two
sides to compromise the willingness to
fight corruption instead of being part
of it those are challenges I never to
share house photo is impossible to
support things from the outside
yeah McConnell districts yes you can
support things at the end of the day you
can't achieve them from the outside but
you can make it clear that cooperation
with Europe runs along certain values
and principles part of the association
agreement is a firm acknowledgement of
values such as the rule of law democracy
stable governments and economies so
that's an influence it's a combination
of European politics Western politics
and the needs of the people
I will pay shall politic vest Alicia
politic viktor yanukovych suppress the
protests of the people chiefly because
they were protesting against his corrupt
system he raised the cost of corruption
in Ukraine so much that people couldn't
stand dealing with it every day
nobody Paizo changes must now follow a
year in tuck coops you answer eleven
when that almost undies instead of the
Havel network in practice and among by
tying economic support to the clear
expectation that they have to deliver on
this you can tell when corruption is
rife whether the judiciary is
independent or not Ukraine's politicians
have to provide evidence and what that
is needs to be clearly defined and as
it's fulfilled it should be checked off
the list when almost a fool apartment
what chances do you see for Ukraine in
terms of binding itself to Europe
and it the perspectiva coats hostage
wouldn't know a feeling of as it is the
best chance both in the short and long
terms is political and economic
stability
Ukraine needs to accomplish that itself
that's the way to join Europe and from
the point of view of the European Union
and other bodies like the IMF political
and economic support will then follow
fully to Sovetov little understood song
avoidant and when you look at this
conflict which spread from Maidan and
went from being about a nation
self-determination to suddenly being a
geopolitical power struggle with a
neighboring country would you have
thought that possible 25 years after the
fall of a wall no I wouldn't have
thought it was possible perhaps it's
something to say about the fact that we
assume that everyone else thinks the way
we do that's a mistake it would be a
mistake to assume others think as we do
in the West perhaps that mistake is
revealed in our relationship to Russia
that we assumed too much on the other
hand that also expresses our desire to
develop a partnership with Russia we've
taken steps towards that hostia but it
just wasn't on our radar with that a
geopolitical conflict would develop out
of this democratic movement because it
was a democratic movement that's hutton
via al least offed himself
does the dog do you think Germany is up
to facing the challenge of this
situation as a whole skin from the fest
alone does Alan estimate given the fact
that we didn't expect this that it took
us by surprise we're playing catch-up
just to understand the situation I think
it was clear after a few days that it's
about much more than
Crimea but it's about more basic
principles that's yeah we in the West
have to have a more unified response and
have to send a clear message to Putin
than Adam we also have to be able to
keep our nerve in today have now begun
to understand the situation
intellectually and politically we have
to inform the people there and
communicate our point of view to them
there's no option that has to be done
when the five of us hand on the question
of what this resolution requires from us
we will grow closer because of it it's a
process of course but that's what I'm
talking about
Putin has changed the West he has made
it more unified he's made Europe
stronger and as I said perhaps he's made
it more capable of being a geopolitical
player mr. butkin thank you and thank
you